They applauded us when we were right,...
...corrected us when we were wrong,...
...and helped us when we didn't know the difference.
They were tough when they had to be,...
...fun when they wanted to be,...
...fair when they ought to be,...
...and compassionate when they needed to be.
Sure, they taught us I before E except after C,...
...A, E, I, O, U, and sometimes Y,...
...and who, what, where, when, why, and how.
But they also taught us that we could do anything,...
...and they believed it.
Every good thing in the world,...
...every song, every invention, every accord, every cure, every word...
...exists because at some point, someone wanted to teach...
...and someone else decided to learn.
Here's to the love of learning and all those who choose to embrace it.